the situation in Hong Kong right now is
escalating at quite a worrying pace
because as Thomas just said the police
have made their first official arrest or
on this national security law about 15
hours after it was first passed and as
you can see here behind me that has not
at all deterred any of these people from
coming out this busy shopping district
here and cause a Bay is filled despite a
very pre-emptive police attempt to clamp
down on dissent now just moment about 15
minutes before I'm speaking to you I was
myself caught up in such police action
because they were coordinating people
they were blocking off a street from the
top to the bottom and then arresting
everybody in it for at least detaining
them momentarily so we see police at
every street corner trying to
essentially prevent any critical mass
from gathering gathering but still you
can see that there are crowds here
they're moving we don't know for the
moment where they will go or whether
they can display their strength by a
March but it does seem that the national
security law we vigorously contested
here on the streets of Hong Kong